- Okay, Bill Goldberg again for
another installment
of Tu's Tutorial.
Mr. Lam, we have seen a number
of competitors
have a huge issue with Slice
Twice.
Please take us through what
they do wrong,
but please show us the
technique to do it properly.
- I've seen guys cut it too
low.
You cut it too low, it's
heavy mass now.
It's gonna fall faster.
You cut it too high, you're not
gonna have enough surface space
on your second cut.
Your first cut needs to set up
for your second cut.
- So how do you place it?
Do you do a straight horizontal
cut?
Do you do an angled cut?
- If I do a horizontal cut,
I'm gonna have to create speed
to punch through, but now look
as the follow though,
now I have to make up all this
time to decelerate...
- Distance is time.
- That cut.
That's right.
So I want to position the
angles of the cut
where it's kind of tracing the
fall of the sugarcane.
So if I'm swinging up here, my
blade's already set
on this side.
All I have to do is just change
the pitch
and come up at a different
angle.
- Understood.
- Because that sugarcane
should be falling and letting
gravity take over.
- Where is the perfect
placement, number one,
and the perfect line for that
second strike?
- So let's say I go too steep
with my angle.
By the time I turn, that
sugarcane is already landing
on that blade.
- Okay.
- I have to create a little bit
of distance
so I can create that curvature
to slice on that second strike.
- I'm gonna step back,
and if you would please, sir,
show us the proper way
that Slice Twice should be
done.
Because God knows we've seen
how not to do it.
- Right.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
- Hiyah!
Ladies and gentlemen, that's
absolutely the most amazing
Slice Twice demonstration I've
ever seen.
So, sir, congratulations.
Thank you very much.
both: [speaking in a foreign
language]
- Ah-pish.
- [chuckles]